[Music]
we have not spoken no uncie you send up
a fight I wish we had a place that would
be great I wish we'd had a fight you and
I are pals but I have not spoken to you
much I just want you on the air since
you hosted the White House
Correspondents Dinner
I know let's get your take on like the
what everything had happened I just want
to hear the the gory details the far I
was well thank God for Conan O'Brien
because he I got on the phone with him
before I got the gig and I was like well
what do you do how do you do this I and
I wish she would used a real phone then
I offer you finger I was very it was I
was praised yes but you are very nicely
let me use your writing staff whom I
mean we didn't use any of their jokes
but it was a good way to go it was a
goodwill gesture you don't want to go
down but it was as you know it's the
craziest gig of all time as you perform
in what's funny they have the the the
president goes first then you go and and
I president is your opener he's the
opening act and then they have and then
they say okay now the comedian will go
and I was curious there's all this stuff
that goes with that giggling white house
tour did you get the White House yeah we
had a white house tour you get a private
tour and then you spend all the money
you have on flying your family out
you really do because they expect it and
if you don't then they will no longer be
your family and I a private tour of the
White House yeah and and who'd you bring
you obviously you bright wife the kids
wife kids mistress mother-in-law my
brothers and we got we've toured thee do
we toured the house and then we got any
private car that they gave to us mhm and
my older brother just goes no kind of
let down no he did gotta let down well
he wanted to see the Oval Office an
angle of Merkel happened to be there
where she well she and Obama are trying
to figure out what to do with Putin and
the Ukraine he's like no that's what I
wanted to see
if they let me in sorry this free trip
is such a bummer so is he like that
about everything this brother that's
just sort of his attitude yeah he's like
no it's fine what that you just met
Scarlett Johansson yeah she seems okay
there was then he then we got to meet
the president beforehand there's a weird
wonderful party beforehand we're like
it's like a hundred people and you have
a meet-and-greet with with the president
and I brought my nine and six-year-old
to that with my wife and again mistress
and everyone else and uh no and you we
were just about to meet the president
and my six-year-old is looking a little
piqued 'add and he begins to vomit at
that party in the party and I've been at
that thing that is a small party it's
not like it's a massive room that's that
will go that will be noticed it was well
noticed by such people as Robert DeNiro
Zooey Deschanel yeah so they so there's
my son just lose it's awful it's real
and I and people like he's pretty
nervous huh I'm like nine six he doesn't
know what's going on and my poor wife is
trying to clean it up and no one's
helping her from the family because
they're like there's Robert DeNiro and
I'm talking about Raging Bull and so
that was really great and then we met
the president and I thought oh well
maybe we'll he'll vomit on him and
that'll be a great story right it would
make the news anyway cool no and so I
think we have a photograph here of you
holding there it is there he is you're
holding him and you can tell that he's
what you feeling well any I would if he
were to vomit it would just kind of go
down my neck so then that's my other son
there with the hair and I said better
you better walk up to the Perot you see
we dressed him I loved his hair it's
this great he's a little hippie kid and
he I said when you walk up to you walk
up to the president and you say hello
and you you shake his hand and he walked
right up and
president knew his name he goes so
you're Edward and he goes I'm Eddie
sorry we corrected the president it's
Eddie okay
okay got it he corrected the president
very nice what you got to do five
seconds of me got to do
you